vox did not support
the latest amendment to the food chain law
which prohibits lost sales
of our farmers and ranchers
and recently just 2 weeks ago
vox voted against
of the last royal decree
presented by the government of spain
with a bedding
with a lot of concrete measures to help families
to workers
and the most affected companies
by the impact of rising prices
of energy
i.e. vox
where you have the opportunity
in this case it is in the shoulder of the deputies.
and support effective measures
that mitigate the situation in the most vulnerable people.
there either does not support or votes against
and then bring the eh autonomic parliaments
where we do not have the competencies
of what you are bringing
eh non-legislative proposals and speeches for the presidency
this royal decree 6 bar 2022 that vox voted against
includes in article 15
bonus
the final price of certain energy products
in article 31
direct aid
to cattle ranchers
sheep and dairy goats that are particularly affected
in 33 more millionaire aids
we are talking about hundreds of millions in each of the
of aspects to the agricultural sector
livestock farmer and excludes article 29 to 34
40 budgetary financial aid
guarantees for liquidity
there are enough gentlemen,
how will they be enough
here we would enter into the budgetary issue
on the money item on the tax item
will never
be enough for the people who are having the hardest time
but they go in the right direction